[Music]
sure the actor who gained prominence as
stiffler in the american pie series and
wheeler in the role model series
still pops up in movies and on tv shows
but not with the regularity or high
profile he once did
here's what happened to sean william
scott in march 2011
sean william scott had to abandon any
career momentum he'd picked up and drop
out of the hollywood entertainment
machine for a while it came as a
surprise to scott's fans
but as it turned out it was absolutely
necessary because he had to get his
personal life in order
according to tmz the actor voluntarily
checked himself
into a treatment facility to address
unspecified health and personal
issues he stayed for 30 days then went
off to film the fourth american pie
movie
american reunion in the decades since
his stint in rehab
scott has never publicly addressed what
issues led to his decision to seek
professional help
nor has he appeared in any tabloid or
media reports getting into trouble
he insisted to people in 2003 i don't
really party
if i did it would probably just be
trying a new bottle of wine
if he's trying to avoid vices or other
triggers for the demons that led him to
step away from his daily life
to get his head clear 10 years ago then
it's probably best he avoids or limits
his time as a hollywood player
which could mean a decreased chance of
landing big roles
in the 2010s sean william scott didn't
do much live-action film work
after american reunion he had leading
roles in just five films throughout the
entire decade
there are plenty of actors who find
themselves part-time performers for
whatever reason
but for the most part they still play
the hollywood game hitting the red
carpet for film premieres and big events
and relentlessly promoting themselves or
their affiliated products on social
media
scott however is not often among them in
contrast to his usual goofball screen
persona
he's more of an actor and less of a
celebrity seemingly happy flying under
the radar
rarely seen at events or even captured
by paparazzi going about his daily
business
cause after i did american pie i bought
this car and i should have saved some of
my money because then i ended up having
to work at the la zoo
in the era of celebrity tabloids and the
24-hour news cycle
this otherwise respectable and tasteful
behavior and commitment to privacy
could have hurt his career if he's not
seen off screen that hurts his
visibility
this could make audiences forget about
him and may also make studios reluctant
to cast an actor who isn't going to play
the game
and give their movies free publicity
with public appearances paparazzi shots
and instagram chatter despite often
playing louts
jerks blowhards and fools sean william
scott has occasionally been given the
chance to play roles that weren't like
stifler
in 2003 for example he co-starred in
bulletproof monk
a comic book adaptation an english
language vehicle for hong kong star
chao young fat a little bit of fantasy a
little bit of comedy
and mostly a martial arts action movie
bulletproof monk
might have been too many things at once
to attract too
big of an audience during its theatrical
run it earned 37 million dollars
worldwide against a 52 million dollar
budget
not only was it a flop with viewers but
critics didn't care for bulletproof monk
either
slate's david edelstein complained of
two quick cuts and
fight scenes that were quote chopped
into scores of little kicks and punches
and leaps that don't cut together
ed gonzalez of slant was even harsher
calling the movie
infinitely juvenile a slam that had to
affect scott
who told the san francisco chronicle
that he made the movie in the hopes that
it would get
quote the audience into that more
serious aspect of what i can do
unfortunately that backfired with scott
bearing part of the blame for the
movie's box office failure
after bulletproof monk scott returned to
the broad ensemble comedy that made him
famous
playing beau duke in the 2005 big screen
remake of the hit television series the
dukes of hazzard
it made 80 million dollars at the
american box office but it was also
slammed by critics
the houston chronicle called dukes the
worst film of the new millennium
it was nominated for seven razzie awards
including worst picture
and it amassed a woeful 14 rating on
rotten tomatoes thanks to a slew of
terrible reviews from publications like
timeout london which
zeroed in on scott calling his
performance quote mildly perverted puppy
dog goofing
in 2007 scott got another shot at
mainstream comedy with mr
woodcock playing a man still tormented
by abuse from his grade school
gym coach played by billy bob thornton
who then starts dating the guy's mother
played by susan sarandon
critics liked it about as much as they
did the dukes of hazzard with ign
calling it an uninspired unfunny and
irritating experience
and dvd town labeling it a depressing
nightmare further damaging scott's bank
ability as a comedy headliner was the
fact that mr woodcock earned a paltry
25 million dollars at the american box
office
with the american pie franchise well
behind him
scott got a rare chance at a dramatic
poignant role
in 2015 with courtney cox's directorial
debut
just before i go scott played a man
going on a farewell
tour of sorts before taking his own life
he told variety
it was rewarding to play pretty much the
antithesis of what i've done in the past
to get a chance to play a totally
different character because he's just a
good average relatable guy going through
obviously an awful moment in his life
was great
unfortunately theater goers and critics
didn't share scott's enthusiasm
on top of the film's staggeringly low 10
970 total box office gross
scott's performance was described as
tepid and
colorless by stephen holden of the new
york times
while justin chang of variety said scott
convinces well enough as a guy who wants
to be put out of his misery and there
isn't an actor here who doesn't look
ready to join him
with his big shot at comedy mixed with
drama ending in disaster
scott hasn't had much of a chance to
flex those particular creative muscles
again
not just a conventionally attractive and
familiar face
john william scott also has a memorable
and distinctive voice
it served him well in his career helping
him create
well-rounded characters in live-action
movies but scott's sound is unique
enough on its own that he's been
able to supplement his flesh and blood
performance work or
replace it entirely during fallow
periods with some prominent
and lucrative voice over work for a
decade he provided the voice of the
excitable prankster possum crash
in the animated ice age franchise scott
first voiced the character in 2006's ice
age the meltdown
and reprised the role in two sequels as
well as tv specials
dvd bonus shorts and video games making
his voice highly recognizable to a
generation of children
so while his fame may come and go
scott's finances and legacy
and children's entertainment are well
secured
at the peak of his career sean william
scott was a casting director's go-to
actor for a high school party boy
college jock or aimless post grad
now that he's aged out of that
demographic he's not going to be offered
those parts anymore
he's so associated with his breakout
role of stiffler that filmmakers and
audiences have a hard time
seeing him as anything else and scott
knows it
in 2010 while promoting the action
comedy cop-out
scott told mtv news that his role as
stiffler may have hurt his career as
much as it helped
saying i had so much fun and loved the
character
i don't want to be known as that
character forever now i'm realizing that
i probably will be known as that
character forever
scott himself is pretty different from
stiffler saying in a 2015 reddit ask me
anything
that he's a huge instigator of trouble
but similarities between him and stifler
in there he said the majority of that
character i took from the friends i went
to high school with
in an interview with ign scott
categorized himself
a nerd in high school who didn't even
consider pursuing a career in comedy
when he first went to hollywood
and they would come up to me like
stifler and when i was like not really
it was like they're i was breaking their
hearts you were telling them you were
telling them there's no santa claus
sean william scott has largely shifted
his efforts to smaller movies
indie movies and working just outside of
the hollywood mainstream
in 2011 he starred as doug a dumb
sweetheart who becomes an
unlikely hockey enforcer in the modestly
budgeted canadian production
goon a box office flop which proved such
an
underground classic that it inspired a
2017 sequel
scott then joined the cast of super
troopers 2 a sequel to another cult
favorite that was produced after
a successful online fundraising campaign
and which earned decent 30 million
dollars at the box office
more recently scott led the cast of the
blumhouse horror movie bloodline where
he played against type as a social
worker and new dad
dealing with and committing unspeakable
acts low-key
slightly off the radar independent films
aren't necessarily going to lead to big
things for scott but he's at least
making a living while also pursuing
interesting projects and putting his
acting chops to use
before his breakout role in american pie
scott did
plenty of tv work appearing on sitcoms
in commercials
and in music videos in the 2010s he gave
the small screen another shot
along with comedy heavy hitters like
chris pratt adam scott
kumail nagioni and elizabeth banks scott
lent his voice to the ifc
project tim's valley a stop-motion
animated project
involving dolls facing hilariously adult
problems
unfortunately the show didn't get a full
series order from ifc
in 2018 scott joined a tv production
that was already in progress
and beset with stress and backstage
drama after numerous on-set
incidents the producers of fox's lethal
weapon fired star claimed crawford
and brought in scott to perform opposite
damon wayans
the new blood didn't save the show with
wayans threatening to leave the series
in the middle of the season
it was a moot point because fox decided
to cancel lethal weapon
in may 2019. not only has his
association with one
extremely over the top role led to some
professional
resistance for sean william scott he
also has to contend with being forever
associated with the franchise
to many filmmakers and film goers scott
isn't just stiffler
he's fully the american pie guy part of
a long-running franchise
forever tied to the late 90s and early
2000s
a very different comedy movie era that's
going to limit the roles he's offered or
allowed to play
and scott isn't alone in this state of
affairs it's a circumstance that his
fellow american pie
cast members have also dealt with on
some level jason biggs
tara reid shannon elizabeth chris klein
eddie k
thomas thomas ian nichols and mina
suvari have similarly struggled over the
past couple of decades to maintain the
career momentum
and mega fame they experienced in the
wake of american pie
eugene levy's doing great though sean
william scott didn't appear in a single
movie or tv show in 2020.
as of 2021 he's got one project in the
offing but it's a big one
fox ordered an american remake of this
country
a popular bbc comic monumentary about
the quirky denizens of a small town
scott is in the cast as father joe and
the series will hit the airwaves in fall
2021
and as long as hollywood stays the
course as it has for years with pumping
out reboots and sequels
scott is in the unique and fortunate
position of being involved with several
franchises
there's always the chance that another
american pie movie will be made
somewhere down the line
and i think we're going to do like
another 40 american pie movies
yeah why not right let's just do it
until we all die
or an ice age movie even the long
disgust and long awaited
seriously dude where's my car could
inner production at any time
any of those could provide scott with
the right environment as part of a big
comic ensemble or having another actor
of his caliber to play off of
to once again capture major success
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one